as guardians of the galaxy in the in the
morning guys we got ourselves the first
teaser trailer for thor love and thunder
and i said white boys wake up
we gotta do this assemble it's only 90
seconds but we you both have to be here
with me
that doesn't do that guys hit that
subscribe button because clearly it's
worth it also leave a like if you can
that means the world i'm sure there's a
song in here that's going to get us
demonetized so we ask that you subscribe
get us closer to that million mark
follow koi zhandra over on tick tock
covers a whole bunch of awesome awesome
possum stuff over there he'll be
breaking this video down as well
specifically the real rejects right now
he'll be breaking down the thor trailer
my comic book expert you better be ready
ready because
you recommend it yeah yeah let's do
[Music]
these this were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
hmm wow i need to figure out simba
exactly who i am
bearing junior man out of thunder man
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment yes guardians of the
galaxy
[Music]
my superheroing days are over
what
come on man
the goats the goat the goats of goats
[Music]
you ever feel lost
on the people that you love
[Music]
not me
just listening
[Laughter]
where's jane
oh
there she
[Music]
yeah that is looks great the mighty thor
indeed that was absolutely a lot in 90
seconds yeah
i love that they're leaning into the
color palette so so much like the 80s
thor costume is kind of a running
commentary on marvel comics like there's
that phase that we don't usually talk
about they're like making it cool which
is what tyka does and that's what taka
does best man yeah and speaking of 80s i
actually really love the choice to use
the song sweet child of mine sweet child
of mine while like a good like a really
cool 80s love rock song towards the
latter part of that song they have that
melody like where do we go now where do
we go so what will be the future of our
relationship there's some like
questioning happening there i feel like
that kind of works on both levels with
this particular trailer his relationship
with being thor his relationship with
being a hero his relationship with being
himself like where do we go now
obviously in this trailer you hear him
saying what was my path is here what do
i continue to do and also when you do
have jane in here as mighty thor where
in the comics correct me the room unless
i put it in the comments i mean
i did read it
but in the comics jane uh she's
diagnosed with cancer through a variety
of circumstances she's able to suddenly
wield the power of thor use
michelle nor magellan
correctly so americans are supposed to
say it yeah use milner but every time
she actually activates herself decreases
the progress of the chemotherapy within
the cancer right so she's fighting it's
weaker every time she uses it i feel
like this song used in here works on so
many levels even though we didn't get to
that part in the song but i know that's
what the song goes that song choice not
only encapsulates the 80s feel to it but
also thematically what thor as a
character is going through here of what
should he do for his future especially
in regards himself and especially in
regards to jane as well it's a song that
harkens to some kind of uh you know
coming of age which it seems like thor's
in a new phase of doing what do i do now
that i've sort of hung up my warrior
lifestyle and i'm trying to live
something that's more sort of bless you
mighty koi
i just love the way it complemented the
colors and the
scope you know like these movies have
tons of scope especially the thor movies
being the sort of epic interpolations
that they are but this one definitely
looks like it's bringing in sort of a
different flavor to that visual
aesthetic like it doesn't look like as
much of a big epic battle movie though
those things will come and i'm excited
to see what the contrast is in the
storyline here because they're not
leading with a ton of action a ton of
fighting we don't even get a glimpse of
gore the god butcher in a very distinct
way that i could notice so i like that
this is mostly honing in on where's thor
now and where do we go from here i love
that it is not only the 80s aesthetic
with thor and that is his way of going
on a walkabout i feel like what he's
embracing as thor is his more fun like
his truthful self it's a it's literally
like an australian walkabout story but
we're also expanding the world in doing
that we got a quick shot of zeus played
by russell crowe we also got you know
our entire guardians of the galaxy so
the scope of this is really big but i
think the details we get the goats the
two the ghost tooth nasher and tooth
grinder that's right tooth dasher tooth
grinder but i do also think the mjolnir
reassembled was interesting because we
saw him bury stormbreaker which is the
last ax and and hammer we saw him wield
but we saw hella destroy mjolnir and
then it looks like it got reassembled to
a clay pot yeah so she's wielding the
reassembled mjolnir so i'm wondering if
like you know maybe she's more worthy
maybe she through you know becoming thor
it reassembled cosmically and what does
that mean for stormbreaker what does
that mean for that journey between them
what does that mean for their
relationship because it's only a minute
and a half trailer and we see him you
know dancing around this pirate sherman
so there's clearly something with
someone else and then thor comes back
this is disney's replacement for pirates
of the caribbean this is it right there
that's how we do it we also saw
our new king of asgard yeah valkyrie
and dealing with local politics looks
like she is hating
dealing with local politics so much it's
the little glimpse you get over her just
she looks bored out of her mind the
parks and rec section of the show strong
being a warrior so i imagine doing like
political [ __ ] is not really what she
actually wants to do but she but she
wants to tend to the people you know so
i'm interested to see what the
bureaucracy is going on in new asgard is
and what all the effects post endgame of
everything that's happening there like
to kind of unpack i also i'm really
excited for the inevitable 80s action
montage if i'm losing the weight that we
got sampled here yeah the chain scene
that i imagine is gonna be a full
sequence of him dropping from fat
thornton mighty thing and then into her
being mighty thor but also his hat
saying strongest avenger because that's
the argument of hulk was it sakara 1.2
yeah that's what i'm wondering because
the the strongest avenger hat felt very
pointed in many directions why would
they go back to car though um maybe to
pick up jeff goldblum i don't know
but jeff goldblum is is currently
crashing with daryl is he right yeah
maybe they went to look for him and
they're like ah he's gone well we should
just clean this up while he's away so
that you know when he gets back he won't
be pissed yeah that's it
it would be great to have a daryl cameo
though i think daryl should finally make
it into the news
carol has earned it i think daryl has
fought long and hard and it's time
best friend hero man team daryl thor
looks great what a beast of a human
being like how does he always find a way
to get larger it is insane
and i and i like what you were saying
about about the 80s vibe and the sort of
commentary that the comics bring in on
the aesthetics and stuff every different
generation and iteration because i feel
like we're at a fortunate time for that
with the movies because we have such a
prevalence of 80s nostalgia within our
pop culture so i feel like this movie
has the opportunity to both poke fun at
certain aspects of you know the comic
runs of the 80s and how those could be
perhaps silly by today's standards but
also to legitimize some of those things
to take something that might have been
silly and make it actually kind of
legitimate or cool i think this has the
chance to make some of the worst ever
thor stories the coolest ever thor
stories because that wrestling outfit is
among the worst costumes of all time in
comic books it's on many lists of how
did this happen and if anyone's gonna
make it cool it is the handsomest and
the tykist and i feel like the guardians
will probably only just be probably in
the like the first act of this movie the
first act but i think they're going to
be a big part of it for a while while
they're in it it's going to be integral
yeah yeah and especially his
relationship with star-lord himself it
seems like that's the main thing they'll
be honing in on what was cool about this
was as much as we're getting in here it
still feels like it's very thor centric
what i found kind of interesting is that
there's a melancholic vibe to it the
last thor movie was just so funny like
it was so fun so entertaining there's a
lot more to it than that but that was
like the main takeaway here you get a
little bit more of the shades of the
jojo rabbit taika ytd in terms of its
more dramatiy effect like you can just
feel that underneath the surface which i
thought was really cool i feel like it's
gonna be more character driven a little
bit more deep and nuanced than thor
ragnarok even was maybe this will be our
thor means death that's more my
preference honestly i like when he's got
a darkness to his comedy and and not in
the david fincher sense but in the
morose uh
coping quality because you know the
world can be dark so if you look at the
the trajectory of the avengers films
you've got captain america going from
self less to selfish through literally
diving on a bomb to like you know
sacrificing everything to go be with his
peggy then you've got tony stark going
from a man who's warmongering to
eventually landing as the guy that does
jive on the bomb and saves us all so
their arc is very specific and the x of
their arc is civil war the only movie
that we didn't have thor in because
thor's entire arc is being certain of
self and then losing sense of self we've
not landed on where that loss of sense
of self is so we've had the trajectory
for the other two of the big three we've
had those landings thor's the only one
that remains and we've had him have more
and more of a crisis of self as the
movies get bigger so i'd love a more
sorrowful conclusion to understand what
thor wants to be and what better way to
do that than have the reflection of self
and jane foster and perhaps his
successor
you sound so stupid
i just stuff you like
listen don't subscribe to koi's channel
don't just take tacos don't you wait
secret goddamn time you guys can
subscribe to us though
leave a like and it's my last time
done with thor love and thunder down
below catch you guys soon